В ефірі «heute journal» з
Гайнцом Вольфом і Марієттою Сломкою.
Доброго вечора!
Протягом тижнів ми були свідками
тривалого протистояння між
міністром охорони здоров'я Карлом Лаутербахом
та міністром юстиції Марком Бушманом.
Поки, нарешті, був представлений проєкт нового закону
про захист від інфекцій.
Це стане оновленням заходів,
спрямованих проти коронавірусу.
Двом політикам виявилось досить складно
знайти компроміс.
Але тепер своє слово скаже влада федеральних земель.
Адже як би там не було, саме їм міністри
передають остаточні повноваження
ухвалення конкретних рішень.
І вони від цього не в захваті.
Сьогодні відбулася відеоконференція.
Однією з головних тем було: коли, де
і чи варто носити маски з осені?
Про це детальніше в репортажі Хайке Сланскі.
Іноді на речі корисно дивитися під іншим кутом.
У Швейцарії більше не діють загальнонаціональні
заходи протидії коронавірусу.
В Австрії також ні.
У Франції анулюють дію паспорта вакцинації.
А в Данії вже кілька місяців зовсім
відсутні обмеження.
У цих країнах коронавірус лікують так само,
як і будь-яке інше вірусне захворювання.
У Німеччині, навпаки, всі між собою сперечаються.
Конференція міністрів охорони здоров'я земель
з федеральним міністром Лаутербахом,
який попри четверте щеплення
зараз хворіє на коронавірус.
Його стратегія на осінній сезон така:
у приміщеннях потрібно носити маски крім випадків
коли людина пройшла тест, нещодавно одужала
або щойно вакцинована.
При цьому вакцинація діє лише три місяці.
Представники федеральних земель
критикують таку позицію.
Землі в основному виступали проти
тримісячного статусу вакцинації,
проти масок та деяких інших обмежень.
Вже є обґрунтовані заяви про те,
що потрібно вносити корективи.
У мене не виникло відчуття,
що міністр прислухався до наших слів
і сприйняв їх серйозно.
Отже, вакцинація як допуск до ресторанів
чи до відвідання громадських заходів без маски.
Міністр виступає за четверте щеплення,
бажано одразу для всіх,
і чинить тиск на постійну комісію з питань
вакцинації, яка відкидає його пропозицію.
Реакція з комісії, звісно, однозначно негативна.
Професор Рюдігер фон Крі:
Краще б Лаутербах навчився трохи притримувати язика.
Справа у тому, що постійна комісія з питань вакцинації
(STIKO) рекомендує
четверте щеплення лише людям віком від 70 років.
Всесвітньо відомий імунолог також дивується
висловлюванням міністра.
Він ставиться до четвертого щеплення критично.
На мою думку, захист від серйозної
форми захворювання після третього щеплення
у довгостроковій перспективі становить 95%.
Насправді імунна система
не може покращити цей показник.
Це вже гарні, просто чудові результати.
З іншого боку,
наявні вакцини не забезпечують
належного захисту від інфікування
і від поширення інфекції.
Тож стоять питання про постійну вакцинацію,
індивідуальний захист та запобігання зараженню інших.
Міністр вже замовив
ще не затверджену, адаптовану вакцину.
Але вчені ставлять під сумнів її ефективність.
Питання в тому,
чи викликають нові вакцини взагалі
хоч скількись варту уваги імунну відповідь,
чи захищають вони від інфекції та зараження інших,
а це досі достеменно не відомо.
Про це ми дізнаємось лише після клінічних досліджень.
І попередньо я налаштований досить скептично.
Як часто варто робити щеплення
та якою вакциною?
Питання, які хвилюють і політиків медичної сфери.
Триває третій рік пандемії.
Ми повинні знайти правила, які люди сприймуть.
Люди мають розуміти, як себе поводити,
і головне - навіщо дотримуватись правил.
Також проти виступає
Вільна демократична партія Німеччини (FDP).
Новий законопроект ще має пройти Бундестаг.
Що ж, двері відчинені.
Маємо на зв’язку федерального міністра
охорони здоров'я.
Він приєднався з ізоляції вдома.
Як ми знаємо, він зараз хворіє на коронавірус.
Доброго вечора, пане Лаутербах!
Як почуваєтесь?
Добрий вечір, пані Сломка.
Мені вже краще.
Мушу зазначити, що симптоми були
сильнішими ніж я очікував.
Був дуже сильний кашель,
лихоманка, я приймав противірусні.
Мені чотири рази робили щеплення.
Все це було нелегко,
але, нарешті, я на шляху до одужання.
Звичайно, було б добре, якби восени
з'явилася вакцина,
яка реально формуватиме імунітет,
тобто яка не тільки захищатиме від дуже важкої форми,
що потребує стаціонарного лікування,
але й від інфікування.
Чи маєте ви оптимістичні сподівання щодо цієї вакцини,
яка зараз проходить необхідні процедури в
Європейському регуляторному агентстві?
Очікуєте результатів до жовтня?
Так, думаю, так і буде.
Зараз все тільки починається.
Ми тісно співпрацюємо з компаніями,
які займаються цією тематикою.
Також ми хочемо залучити
Інститут імені Пауля Ерліха в Лангені.
Тож результати мають бути наприкінці вересня
або на початку жовтня.
Нова вакцина має захистити від інфікування.
Я не думаю, що такий захист буде ідеальним,
втім кращого варіанту за цю вакцину зараз немає.
У нас вже є чудові засоби боротьби з хворобою,
але вони безсилі проти поширення інфекції.
Натомість нові вакцини зможуть значно ефективніше
захищати саме від поширення хвороби.
Одна річ, яку я не зовсім розумію:
якщо кращі вакцини будуть через три місяці,
то чому Ви закликаєте продовжувати робити
четверте щеплення зараз?
Навіщо використовувати вакцину,
яка не захищає від інфікування?
Крім того, коли ми отримаємо нові вакцини,
лікар скаже, що потрібно трохи почекати
перед наступною вакцинацією.
Ні, я до цього не закликаю.
Це спотворення моїх слів,
оскільки вони в першу чергу стосуються
людей похилого віку або тих,
хто перебуває в установах догляду.
Але ж Ви казали про четверте щеплення для всіх?
Саме про це був конфлікт між Вами
та комісією з вакцинації?
Ні, я не казав, що це стосується всіх.
Зазначу, що йшлося про людей похилого віку,
наприклад, 60 або 70 років,
таку вакцинацію для них потрібно
узгоджувати з лікарем.
Це залежить, наприклад, від того,
з якою кількістю людей контактує особа.
Те, що зранку може здаватися застудою,
пообіді стане важкою інфекцією.
Однак Ви вже зробили четверте щеплення і
коментували, що це доцільно.
Так, вірно,
оскільки я дуже багато контактую з різними людьми,
то все-таки підхопив інфекцію.
Щоб цього не сталося, ви можете зробити наступне:
на мою думку, ті, хто перебуває у групі
високого ризику,
люди похилого віку, ті, хто потребує догляду,
або ті, що мають тяжкі хвороби,
не повинні чекати на нову вакцину.
До того часу ви можете підхопити інфекцію.
І перебіг хвороби може бути складнішим.
Чекати тим, хто в групі ризику,
неправильно.
Майже всі вчені радять цього не робити.
Зараз не варто місяцями чекати на нові вакцини,
оскільки наявні вакцини
надійно захищають від смерті
та важкого перебігу хвороби.
Отже, це для людей, які ще не отримали щеплень.
Це суперечка, у якій залишається багато незрозумілого:
міністр каже про щеплення для всіх, комісія заперечує,
тепер Ви також кажете, що це не для всіх.
Так само і з цими новими правилами носіння масок,
які Ви узгодили з паном Бушманом.
Тобто тим, хто був вакцинований
не пізніше 3 місяців тому,
восени не потрібно носити маску в приміщенні,
Як це контролюватимуть?
Як людина в ресторані доводитиме вакцинацію?
Адже паспорти вакцинацій вже відмінили.
Я думаю, що зараз багато плутанини створюють люди,
які хочуть підняти галас.
Наприклад, я ніколи не казав,
що всі молоді люди зараз повинні робити щеплення.
Це неправильно, мені знову приписали ці слова.
Я ніколи цього не казав.
Те саме стосується питання про те,
кому потрібно буде носити маску в приміщенні.
Загалом правило просте.
Носіння маски - загальноприйнята вимога.
Якщо землі так вирішать, ви йдете в ресторан у масці.
Те саме стосується культурних заходів та публічних зборів,
відвідувань громадських місць.
Однак є винятки для тих,
хто нещодавно вакцинувався.
Так, ми зрозуміли це, але як саме це виглядатиме
і звідки це випадкове число - три місяці?
Хтось має стояти у ресторані і контролювати
наявність і час щеплення?
Виглядає як дуже ненадійна система контролю.
Ні, це не так.
Ми завжди працюємо з граничними значеннями.
Планується, що поки сертифікат дійсний,
у застосунку «Corona-Warn-App» він буде іншого кольору,
Наприклад, не блакитного, як зараз, а зеленого.
Тож коли людина входитиме до приміщення,
одразу буде видно,
чи дійсний цей сертифікат.
Не потрібно ускладнювати собі життя,
там, де це зайве.
Землі, ресторани, готелі вже мають досвід
такого контролю.
Раніше контролювати правила було
значно складніше.
Зараз можна просто показати додаток
«Corona-Warn-App» і все.
Процедура максимально проста.
Як ви думаєте, чи пройде законопроєкт
через Бундестаг?
З постійною критикою земель,
що незрозуміло, що і коли запроваджувати?
Там дуже прості критерії,
які ми прописали:
висока смертність, тяжкий перебіг захворювання,
перезавантаженість лікарень,
зокрема відділень реанімації та інтенсивної терапії.
Усе це ми вже робили.
Ці критерії ухвалять на рівні земельних урядів.
На їхній основі видадуть відповідні укази.
Усе це ми вже проходили.
Тому насправді критика полягає дещо в іншому.
Ми хочемо впровадити правила,
за якими нам вже доводилося жити.
Багато хто проти.
Вони просто хочуть жити далі, як і раніше.
Вони вважають, що пандемія закінчилася
і восени потрібно послабити обмеження.
Це дасть новий поштовх поширенню інфекції.
Уряд не хоче цього допустити.
Тут я погоджуюся з паном Бушманном,
адже це спричинило б занадто багато
летальних випадків, ми не можемо цього допустити.
З нами на зв'язку був Карл Лаутербах.
Щиро дякую за бесіду, одужуйте.
Інтерв'ю ми записали наперед.
А тепер огляд новин продовжить Гайнц Вольф.
Експрезидент США Трамп заявив,
що агенти ФБР здійснили обшук його резиденції.
Трамп перебував у Нью-Йорку
на момент здійснення рейду його маєтку «Мар-а-Лаго»
в місті Палм-Біч, штат Флорида.
Як повідомляють ЗМІ,
об'єктом уваги ФБР стали державні документи,
які Трамп забрав з собою в маєток.
Трамп засудив рейд, який буцімто
«не був необхідним або доречним».
Китай вже п'ятий день поспіль
продовжує військові навчання
біля узбережжя Тайваню.
За даними Народно-визвольної армії Китаю,
до навчань залучили
військово-морські й повітряні сили.
Тайвань звинувачує Китай
у підготовці до можливого вторгнення на острів,
тому провів власні військові навчання
із залученням важкого озброєння.
Китай розпочав навчання минулого тижня
після візиту американської високопосадовиці
Ненсі Пелосі до Тайваню.
Громадяни Кенії проголосували за нового президента
і членів парламенту країни.
Попри те, що в минулому
вибори часто супроводжувалися заворушеннями,
цього разу вони минули мирно.
Успішний бізнесмен Руто,
який досі був віцепрезидентом країни,
має великі шанси на перемогу.
Його однопартієць, чинний президент Кеніятта,
підтримує політика Одінгу,
який вже впродовж багатьох років очолює опозицію.
Головними питаннями виборчої кампанії були
економічний спад країни й високий рівень інфляції.
У японському місті Нагасакі
вшанували пам'ять жертв ядерного бомбардування,
яке вчинили США 77 років тому.
У контексті російсько-української війни
мер Нагасакі застеріг світ
від застосування ядерної зброї,
нагадавши про її небезпеку
і назвавши загрозу «відчутною кризою сьогодення».
9 серпня 1945 року за три дні після атаки на Хіросіму
США скинули на Нагасакі ядерну бомбу.
Унаслідок бомбардування
загинуло приблизно 70 тис. осіб.
У контексті війни в Україні поширюється новина про те,
що сьогодні в Криму лунали потужні вибухи.
Повідомляють, що у російському військовому аеродромі,
розташованому біля морського курорту,
були підірвані один або декілька складів боєприпасів.
Багато свідків підозрюють, що вибухи відбулися
внаслідок операції української сторони.
У цьому разі це була б перша атака на Крим
за 12 років анексії півострова Росією.
Проте російська сторона заспокоює населення,
мовляв, жодного ворожого втручання не було.
Міністерство оборони України наразі повідомило,
що не може назвати причину детонацій,
і додало, не без самовтіхи, що в таких місцях
важливо дотримуватися «суворих правил
пожежної безпеки», зокрема заборони куріння.
Так українська сторона фактично
передбачила пояснення,
яке згодом надали росіяни:
вибухи відбулися
через порушення правил техніки безпеки.
Найближча лінія фронту пролягає
за 200 км від місця вибуху,
в Херсонській області.
Саме там наша репортерка Анна Брюль
супроводжувала українських військових.
З міркувань безпеки ми надягнули шоломи і жилети -
на цьому наполягли солдати,
які відвезли нас на свої позиції біля південного фронту.
Перед нами - безлюдні вулиці,
які пролягають вздовж покинутих сіл.
«Андре» веде нас до бліндажа.
Як і майже всі військові,
він називає нам лише свій позивний.
«Нам треба максимально багато зброї
у максимально короткі терміни.
Тоді ми швидко закінчимо цю війну.
Я хочу нагадати, що Україна сьогодні
захищає не тільки свою землю, дітей, жінок,
а й усю Європу».
Нам не можна казати, де саме ми перебуваємо.
Бліндажі тут залишилися ще з часів російського наступу,
про це нам розповідає командир підрозділу.
«Зараз ми перебуваємо на їхніх позиціях.
Деякі бліндажі залишилися від них.
Все інше ми копали власноруч».
Надати більше інформації він не може.
Наприклад, про те, який вигляд має ймовірне просування
українських військових на Півдні.
У солдатів «Сатани» зараз оперативна пауза.
Серед військових багато добровольців.
В одному з сіл ми зустріли людей.
Коли прийшла війна, вони просто тут залишилися.
«Вони весь час стріляють.
І вдень, і вночі, і сильно, і помаленьку - як хочуть.
Це нормально».
Любов розповідає, що в неї світло ще є,
принаймні більшість часу.
Через військових вона отримує продуктові набори.
Ми запитали,
що вона робить, коли бої стають занадто інтенсивними.
«Якщо це легкий обстріл,
ми залишаємося тут, на стільчиках.
Якщо ж бомблять сильно, то відчиняємо підвал
і ховаємося там».
То так можна спуститися в підвал?
Любов так робила вже дуже часто -
вона та її чоловік з ампутованою ногою.
Вони щоночі сплять у підвалі.
«Нам здається, що це найбезпечніше місце.
Але ми не знаємо напевне.
Тут і спимо».
Кожну зустріч для нас організовували
українські військові.
Наступна зупинка - знищена російська військова техніка.
Однак у голосі Андре не чути тріумфу.
«Нам потрібно скоріше закінчувати цю війну,
щоб було менше втрат як з нашого боку,
так і з боку Російської Федерації.
Хай ідуть у свою країну і роблять що хочуть.
Ми на них не нападали.
Це вони сюди приїхали».
Українці повідомляють про контрнаступ,
росіяни посилюють свої війська.
На південному фронті бої невпинно тривають.
Невелика поправка: я сказала, що росіяни
анексували Крим 12 років тому.
Я помилилася, це відбулось у 2014-2015 роках.
Перемога Путіна у цій війні
стала б катастрофою не лише для України
та європейських демократичних країн,
хоч би що ми не розуміли під словом «перемога».
Катастрофою це було б
і для сусідньої країни, Білорусі.
Крах України
позбавив би білоруську опозицію останньої надії.
Рівно два роки тому
в Білорусі відбулися акції протесту,
до яких долучилися сотні тисяч громадян.
І вони це не забули.
Більше - у сюжеті Акселя Шторма.
Ігор Ілляш згадує щасливі моменти свого життя:
ніжність, ласку, свою дружину.
Мене дуже вражає те,
як Катя витримує це випробування,
як вона поводиться в цій ситуації.
Два роки тому журналістці
Катерині Андрєєвій (на фото - справа) було 26 років.
Тоді вона з колегою Дар'єю Чульцовою
наживо транслювала протести в Мінську.
Це були протести проти фальсифікованих виборів,
проти тирана,
проти жорстокості, арештів і тортур.
За світле майбутнє всієї країни.
Обох жінок було засуджено до позбавлення волі:
Чульцову - до двох років,
Андрєєву - до восьми років і трьох місяців.
«Немає жодних сумнівів у тому,
що це помста за її роботу,
що ця кримінальна справа
безпосередньо пов'язана з її діяльністю.
Багато доказів були побудовані так,
нібито вона зрадила державну таємницю
іноземній організації.
Андрєєва і Чульцова працювали для польського каналу.
Білорусь сьогодні -
це царство терору, навіть якщо за вікном сяє сонце.
Ув'язнено сотні журналістів та опозиціонерів
за сфабрикованими справами.
Протести в країні стихли.
Багато хто вважає, що на це є лише одна причина:
очільник РФ
забезпечує політичне виживання Лукашенка.
Але кататися з Владіміром Путіним
на човні небезпечно -
море може бути бурхливим,
а подарунків немає.
«Так, станом на сьогодні Лукашенко переміг.
Втім, питання полягає в тому,
яка ціна цієї перемоги. А ціна ця дуже висока.
І її має платити Білорусь».
З початком російської
«військової спецоперації» в Україні
Путін надав своєму другові Лукашенку
чималий рахунок за свої послуги.
Лукашенко залишається президентом,
але Путін розміщує свої війська в Білорусії.
Росія щедро роздає кредити,
але, можливо, колись Москва вимагатиме
участі білоруських солдатів на фронті.
«Країна платить втратою суверенітету
й економічною кризою,
яку спричинили санкції».
Це призводить до глибокого розколу суспільства.
Опозиція, що переважно працює у вигнанні,
також розділилась.
Навіть Світлана Тихановська
суперечлива у своїх же лавах.
Багато хто розчарований результатом, досягнутим наразі.
Два роки тому Білорусь відчувала новий початок.
Відчувала, мабуть, свободу.
Тепер здається, що все це було дуже давно.
Повернемось до Німеччини.
Гайнц розповість про новини економіки.
У важливих водних шляхах, наприклад, у Рейні, зараз
спостерігається частково низький рівень води.
Це впливає і на економіку.
Йдеться не лише про обсяги завантаження
та вартість самих перевезень,
варто звернути увагу і на загальне
економічне зростання. Стефані Баррет.
Через те, що з початку тижня рівень води знову знизився,
вантажний рух річками Німеччини
дедалі частіше зупиняється.
Це призводить до подальшого гальмування
економічного двигуна.
Експерти очікують на сповільнення економіки
в третьому кварталі.
Оскільки внутрішнє судноплавство є
надзвичайно важливою складовою логістики
для німецької промисловості.
Велика кількість мазуту та дизельного палива
постачається Рейном до Німеччини.
Зерно, сировина, хімікати і вугілля імпортують річками,
завжди з урахуванням рівня води.
Особливо низьким зараз є рівень води Рейну
у вузькому місці поблизу Кобленца.
Зараз під кілем кораблів є лише пів метра води.
Для повністю завантажених суден
потрібно півтора метра.
Через це наразі завантажують
лише третину місткості судна.
Зараз клієнтам часто потрібні три кораблі,
щоб доставити їхні замовлення,
а це впливає на ціни.
Найбільшою проблемою наразі
є вугільні електростанції:
через те, що з Росії постачається дуже мало газу,
вони є особливо важливими для
виробництва електроенергії.
Через затяжну ситуацію із рівнем води
деякі постачальники енергії хочуть
зменшити виробництво.
Внутрішнє судноплавство востаннє пережило
такий низький рівень води 2018 року,
тоді витрати на подальші заходи були також високими.
Тож це явище не нове.
Адаптаційні заходи, такі як поглиблення
судноплавних каналів,
є нагадуванням для внутрішнього судноплавства.
Але допоки ця проблема буде вирішена,
ймовірно, Рейн втратить ще багато води.
Стефані Баррет, дуже дякую!
Цього року премію Георга Бюхнера отримає
письменниця турецького походження
Еміне Севгі Оздамар.
Журі каже, що німецька література завдячує їй
«високопоетичним звучанням».
Її автобіографічні романи, п'єси та оповідання
часто присвячені німецько-турецькій історії.
Нагородження відбудеться в листопаді.
Через тиждень після фіналу чемпіонату
з футболу серед жінок Канцлер Шольц
сьогодні відвідав Німецький футбольний союз.
Мова також йшла про різні нагороди
для жіночих та чоловічих команд.
Канцлер зустрічається із керівництвом
Німецького футбольного союзу
та закликає до рівного ставлення
до жіночих та чоловічих команд.
Шольц вимагав однакової оплати вже під час
чемпіонату Європи з футболу серед жінок.
Крилатою фразою «рівна оплата»
він розгорнув дискусію.
Також він виступає за однакові винагороди.
Я вважаю, що це політична тема,
а не просто обговорення зарплат,
які успішні гравці проводять деінде.
Тому тут є сенс обговорювати
однакові винагороди.
Тренерка національної збірної Фосс-Текленбурґ
також просила у «Аktuelle sportstudio»
про коригування нагород
за титул жіночої та чоловічої збірних.
Ми хочемо однакову оплату титулів,
для чоловіків її потрібно трохи знизити,
а нам підняти.
Адже я вважаю таку оплату зависокою.
Я готовий обговорити в наших комітетах,
чи актуальна наша система винагород,
яка зростала протягом десятиліть.
Ще з періоду Чемпіонату Європи вимоги такі:
базова зарплата, рівні можливості,
показ матчів у прайм-тайм,
більше видимості та визнання.
Сьогоднішня зустріч показала,
що бажання змін є.
Завтра в Мюнхені розпочнеться церемонія відкриття,
що дещо нагадує про Олімпійські ігри 1972 року.
Олімпійські ігри, які запам'яталися у всьому світі.
Які розпочались так гарно, аж поки не настав жах.
Убиті ізраїльські спортсмени,
безпосередньо в Німеччині.
Ми згадуватимемо про це також найближчими днями.
Але Чемпіонат Європи має насамперед
продовжити бадьорий дух 72-го.
Дев'ять Чемпіонатів Європи
в історичних місцях.
Штефан Ляйферт із репортажем з Мюнхена.
Виникає відчуття ностальгії, коли Мюнхен
знову виставляє свій всесвітньо відомий
шатровий дах.
«Назад до дахів» - так організатори назвали те,
що тут відбудеться завтра.
Суміш спорту та культури,
конкурс, фестиваль і вечірка - все разом.
Через 50 років після Олімпійських ігор
місто пробуджує дух 1972 року.
Це означає, що ми хочемо повернутися
до спадщини 72-го.
Лише до позитивної спадщини.
Поки тіні вбивства не затьмарили ігри,
Мюнхенська «Олімпія» була зразком
сучасних спортивних подій:
легко та прозоро, доступно та весело.
До гігантоманії сьогоднішніх спортивних подій
тоді було ще далеко.
Тоні Енґельгард мав безпосередній стосунок
до Олімпійських ігор 1972.
Тут, у спортзалі, у свої двадцять років
він координував змагання з гімнастики.
Він вважає, що це чудово, що той самий зал,
та сама підлога
через 50 років знову стають місцем проведення змагань.
Це велике приміщення наповниться життям.
Що може бути кращим?
Я був на різних олімпійських об’єктах, у Туріні тощо.
Спортивні приміщення повністю занедбані.
А тут, у Мюнхені, його бережуть і цінують.
Постійність - це ключове слово Мюнхенських
Міні-Олімпійських ігор 2022.
Дев'ять видів спорту, дев'ять європейських чемпіонатів
і жодної новобудови.
Олімпійський стадіон для легкої атлетики,
колишня дистанція в Обершляйсгаймі для чемпіонату
Європи з веслування на байдарках та каное,
в Олімпійському парку Чемпіонат Європи з
маунтенбайку та веломотокросу.
Перетин фінішної лінії для марафону
розташований в центрі Мюнхена.
А історична королівська площа зараз є
стадіоном для пляжного волейболу.
Вхід переважно безкоштовний, Чемпіонат Європи
буде масштабним і водночас доступним.
Чемпіонати відбудуться на 13-ти локаціях.
Усюди є на що подивитись, всюди можна піти.
Багато чого можна робити безкоштовно.
Це особливий досвід.
Це щось новеньке.
Ця спортивна подія буде чимось більшим,
ніж просто спортом.
Майже десяток сцен в Олімпійському парку
готові для музики, діджеїв, артистів.
Доріан і Феліцітас приїхали аж з Берліна
для встановлення сцен.
Бути частиною цієї спортивної події, працювати разом,
та пропонувати свої роботи великій платформі,
щоб представити себе.
Мюнхен дуже демонстративно намагається
створити масштабну подію, яку полюблять.
Чи Німеччина таким чином обережно підходить
до нової заявки на Олімпіаду?
Якщо ми продемонструємо
нашим мультиспортивним заходом,
що великі спортивні події знову можливі,
що вони можуть бути тривалими
і що люди можуть брати в них участь,
якщо ми створимо таку атмосферу, тоді, я думаю,
Німеччина знову зможе подати заявку
на Олімпійські ігри.
Через два дні 4700 спортсменів розпочнуть боротьбу
за 177 золотих медалей.
Перемога Мюнхена в дисципліні
олімпійської ностальгії беззаперечна.
Це всі новини на сьогодні.
Далі в ефірі репортажі «37 Grad»,
сьогодні з багатообіцяльною назвою:
«Пропонуй замок, шукай співмешканців».
О 00:20 в ефірі наш «Heute journal up:date»
із Назан Гекдемір.
До завтра!
Доброго вечора! Поговоримо про погоду.
Надзвичайно посушлива ситуація у Європі
змінюється лише трохи.
Зараз ми спостерігаємо пояс високого тиску,
який тягнеться від Атлантики до Східної Європи.
До нас дійде порівняно тепле, частково гаряче повітря.
Так температура на заході Німеччини
підвищиться до 30°С і трохи вище.
Дощів поки що не спостерігається.
До неділі в Німеччині на сході та південному сході
можливі окремі грози.
Від одного до десяти літрів у напрямку Іспанії,
надто мало дощу.
Лише у напрямку Італії можуть пройти
сильні зливи та грози,
до 70 л на квадратний метр.
Вночі буде сухо з переважно ясною погодою.
У напрямку Балтійського моря проясниться.
Частково утвориться туман.
Температура знизиться до 9°С в Альпах
та до 10°С у Північнонімецькій низовині.
Значно тепліше у напрямку регіону Рейн-Майн - 18°С.
Завтрашній день буде дуже сонячним,
майже безхмарним, але із сильним східним вітром.
Він може бути поривчастим,
але тоді його легше перенести,
особливо з вищими температурами до 32°С
на південному заході Німеччини та на Нижньому Рейні.
На узбережжі температура сприятливіша - 22°С.
У наступні дні температура продовжує підніматись.
У четвер зовсім сухо до 33°С,
у п'ятницю на Півдні поодинокі грози,
в суботу - на Сході. Температура до 35°С.
Гарного вечора!